windows computers just don't
work i have what i think is the best
list of life hacks
i've ever had it is a waterproof notepad
for the shower
[Laughter]
someone we know was doing lateral raises
with um the metal dumbbells
and between reps he just dinked his
blend between the dumbbells
and that was game over he just like
stops the workout went home
it is another lifx episode tools tactics
and techniques for a productive and
efficient life
we'll be going through some of the life
hacks that we've found over the last few
months
telling you what we think of them and
then the other two people are going to
tear them to pieces
if you like the sound of them they will
be linked in the show notes below either
on amazon or
a website or even just a sentence so
johnny i've got a present for you here
i'm not sure if you can see that
oh yes this is a very i mean it's
it's burning my fingers i'm having to
sort of so if johnny if you can just
what we all need is a potato prop yeah
well you've got one and then
dean can make it look like a real potato
yeah but this is a real potato
you're up first johnny what have you got
it's like room temperature but i'm happy
to catch it so
i have what i think is the best list of
life hacks
i've ever had in the history of life
hacks
i think i've already told you this but
it is a
waterproof notepad
for the shower
so i i have
the most ideas and thoughts that ever
occurred to me all day
happen in the shower and what i do
is like try and leave my phone within
sort of kind of touching distance so
that hey siri
exactly so that that doesn't work
because the sound of the water
is louder or like gets in the way and
then you try and
make a note on your phone with shower
hands and it's just not going to happen
because it's like
you end up typing the wrong word so i
bought it off amazon
it's waterproof paper with a waterproof
pencil it's a
suction onto like a tile or glass and i
just write it down and then when i get
out the shower i pull the thing off
put it in my omnifocus captured
turn showers i reckon i reckon we've
generated revenue
now from my showers
how does a waterproof pencil and
waterproof paperwork
it's like um it's hard to describe
to be honest it is like no other person
paper i've ever used in my life
so it's it looks like a pencil it
functions like a pencil
but somehow you're able to write on wet
paper and it
works and it doesn't wash off it's
brilliant
absolutely brilliant but of course this
i suppose this requires
so i suppose it's part of a general kind
of way that i'm
trying to improve my life which is i'm
so confident now we're not really
focused because it's so much better than
tick tick
that i know that the only thing i need
to do
is make sure i'm capturing everything so
i have like a
a pad of paper for when i'm meditating
because that's another time that it
happens
and i have this in the shower and then i
use like siri in the car
and my airpods are on training and
things like that so it's just it's just
a game of
how how do i ensure that nothing slips
through the cracks
and the shower the waterproof part of
paper is uh
is the one i'm most proud of any
questions
you've got a lot of use out of it so far
loads
you said you like i think you must have
a really high density of shower thoughts
so it's it's an average of like three to
four things a shower how long's a shower
for you
five minutes sometimes longer
what's interesting is i found shower
thoughts correlate with
viral tweets for me so there's been
times when i've poured my heart into
crafting a tweet that i think yeah this
ticks all the boxes to
gain traction gain followers go viral
tumbleweeds
and then a stupid shower thought that
you just think oh just
next day you wake up and it's got
thousands of likes and you're like oh
yeah that would be good like a
waterproof ipad built into the wall
i did i think anything that increases or
reduces friction for capture
is going to be a winner i don't think i
have
very many ideas in the shower but i tend
to shower on a night and you tend to
shower in the morning
don't you yeah yeah so
by 9 p.m 10 p.m at night when i'm
having my shower like i'm i'm all idead
out
so a few of these life hacks came from
shower shower capture wow
okay last episode johnny you were
showering in the night time
because of sleep quality so i do after
the training
i share in the night time after training
but not every night
interesting there we go youssef what you
got for us
so i've got an anti-hack to start with
and the reason i'm saying this is
because it might impact
this episode i've ordered a new dashcam
because last time i had a car crash my
dash cam didn't pick up the footage
because
it was so old so i got the worst of both
worlds
and because it's over a hundred pounds
value
amazon have now started doing a one-time
password
that you have that they send you within
five minutes of the delivery man coming
and you have to quickly
tell him the passcode and then you take
your leave and go
so the the problem is this might happen
now
so yesterday i was on a podcast with
johnny and mano henselman's
the amazon man was like absolutely
governmental on the door
and my flatmate answered the door and he
couldn't accept the parcel because he
didn't have the password
you're thinking would someone really
like break into my house
to take a parcel
to get a dashcam like it it's it's
health and safety gone mad
so what's the hack so the hack is like
yes it's a nice piece of security just
like online banking but it's possible to
lock yourself out of
your own accounts in many ways where it
so i actually um anti
i know everyone's all like oh you need
two factor authentication and one time
passwords and stuff
but i think it's a pain the hack off the
back of it
is if you want to avoid that and there's
certain accounts that you have to use
for you know when it texts you a
verification code and you have to type
it in
is use safari because safari will auto
pull it in from your phone
and then you just put your finger on the
touch id and it'll
fill it in does that work with
everything so does that work with
paypal for example yeah just
sent to your number if it's sent to mine
then of course
but so the point is like instead of
having because a lot of a lot of
companies have two factor authentication
now
but i guess because cyber crimes
increased i assume because of
the last year so you can just get rid of
that
and do with your face if you use safari
on
your computer you can do it with your
finger i think they're going to launch
face id in the next generation of marks
oh okay
face id on mac with a slightly more
robust
um set of payment presets and address
and details and all that sort of stuff
is going to be so good matthew kobach
that i had on the show a while ago
owns fast and the goal of fast is that
you never need to put your payment
details in
again um so that's like a cross-platform
solution for this
so you'd have your fast membership and
that would be
across any website ever that you go into
it'll just auto populate
um it's cool it's just a real slippery
slope but it's so convenient
lots of people are buying stuff through
ecom and
other online stores and they can't be
asked to put their
put their details in right my first one
this is taken from eliezer yukowski who
is one of the guys behind lesrong.com
part of the rationalist movement
um and he was talking about how he
encourages himself to get out of bed
given that i've had a pretty
unstable sleep and wake pattern for
quite a long time getting out of bed
even
during covid just sinking into a regular
sleep and wake pattern has been
challenging
and for me if i get out of bed on time
when i said i would most of the rest of
the day goes right
whereas if i don't get out of bed at the
time that i said i would i would the
rest of the day often tends to be a
catastrophe
um so getting out of bed not staying in
bed not hitting the snooze button
those are all important things for me to
make sure happen
um i'm using two different sunrise alarm
clocks
to because it's quite dark at the moment
so that's the first thing but i've
already spoken about that ellie ed says
uh advice is to count down from 10
and breathe quickly with each count so
if you think about anyone that's ever
done a crossfit workout or any sort of
high intensity class
the coach will look at you if you're not
doing something and go
three two one back on the bar and
there's something about a countdown that
forces you into action
and gets yeah he's like why count it
down from three like i've got to do it
um and honestly if you struggle to wake
up on a morning i was
i am one of those people count down from
10
and big breath with each one
honestly it's it's such a it's such an
easy hack because you
i'm there's no way i'm going back to
sleep after 10 breaths plus i counted
down and then you just throw the covers
off you
and you're up yeah exactly you're full
of full of o2
and the covers are off so what what i
have a similar contraption which is um
when when my alarm goes off i've got a
spring load at the head of my bed
which flips me up and drops me into some
trousers do you
need the dog to press that though the
the dog presses it
and the toaster comes up in the air
the potato gets baked exactly
the only problem is if you're out of
toast because then it'll ping up the jam
should be hits you in the face then it's
the wrong choice i i don't believe that
for a moment because you have cereal for
breakfast rather than toast the rest of
it was fine
you know what the there's a few little
moments like that where you get rumbled
for a little detail like
someone went into my flatmate's bedroom
and wrote him a
semi-illegible note and he and he came
in he was like you said did you
write me that hang on you don't have a
pen
yeah how do you guys make sure that you
wake up on time on the morning i know
you're alarm free now johnny i know it's
great so that's like the
the biggest win of 2020 for me was
that's just
because every day was so similar there
was no like no social stuff in the
evening or nothing to throw me off
um some some of it is is back on my
girlfriend to be honest
like she she loves sleep whereas i find
sleep and inconvenience so like she
wants to go to bed same time every day
so that's kind of my bedtime alarm
like tv's off so i'm just gonna sit in
the dark on my own so i go to bed at the
same time roughly
and then just having the same wake time
every day
for a year and now like i've even tried
so recently kind of tried to get a bit
more sleep
try to like push my my sleep time my
wake time back a little bit and i can't
we need to get back on the podcast she's
just got the wisdom of her forefathers
isn't she like
drilled she i don't think she'd want to
come on the podcast i'll ask her that if
chris wants her on
blood she
i suppose right now not necessarily that
relevant but when gyms are back open
again
i ordered um so
i don't often use dumbbells in training
because a lot of the things i would use
dumbbells for
i'm limited because i'm so muscly and
strong
i'm limited by being able to get the
dumbbell in position so like dumbbell
press incline press overhead press
i just can't like i can't i'm not strong
enough to get it in position and then
use the
um the range of motion so i ordered from
uh
like it was like there's they used to be
on amazon they're not anymore they're
now on like fitness superstore or
something
power hooks which they're only like 20
30 quid
so you could take them to a gym with you
it's a metal handle
that wraps around the dumbbell and then
attaches to the handle itself and you
hold on to it and you're able to
basically unwrap the dumbbells as you
would a barbell
so in a understanding of head press you
just hook them onto like a rig or
a barbell shoulder shoulder height or
unrack it like a bench press
and suddenly dumbbell variations become
how much weight can you use on the
dumbbell variation no shoulder injuries
brilliant brilliant so they are like
they're like 20 30 quid
put them in your gym bag and then sorted
what is your number one dumbbell
movement
that you've missed or the what is the
movement that dumbbells give you that
you think a barbell can't
like the most what's the first place
that you go to with regards to a
dumbbell movement
so for me i've always found when i do
dumbbell bench press
it helps my bench press which i know
like obviously
but like i'm always limited by just
being able to get there you have to like
get the dumbbells on your knees and then
lie back and like flap around and then
getting them off against the pain
so dumbbell bench press for me is the
biggest thing and i don't like
overhead press with a barbell
particularly it just
doesn't my shoulders don't like it
whereas dumbbells because you can
kind of angle dumbbell and it's a it's
an easier range of motion so
those two like the most obvious that's
why i bought them that's pretty good um
yeah it's awesome i like it man i am
i really fell in love with seated strict
press
seated strict overhead press this year
um
such a good exercise because it's very
nice yeah you can just get yourself
locked in especially if you have a
little bit of spinal instability like me
and sef do
like you can just brace yourself again
so you'd have to bench at
that one like the first the first notch
that allows you to sit back a tiny bit
and then you can give your upper back a
little bit of room
and i think it'll be interesting to see
if you find that overhead
position uncomfortable from a seated
strict press
johnny because it's um it's a lot more
comfortable for me
so i don't have a an incline bench i
train in my like i have a gym in my
garage and i don't have an incline bench
so i'm limited with that but got dining
chairs though
i do i've never thought about that you
know
but that literally would fix the problem
well did you not see this
over summer when the first lockdown
happened there was tons and tons of
videos of like
lads in the garden i with like
some unfortunate garden trestle chair
it's just a you know like a classic
plastic bbq chair
and they've got themselves plus like
quite a bit of weight and you can
see the legs are just going like this
horrible i think like
falling with a barbell in your hands
while you're falling it just it's awful
isn't it the thought of it
so much can go wrong yeah i've seen
people put
barbells on wheelie bins like two
wheelie bins and then the wheelie bin
lids came in and stuff like that
um i think we've we've probably had
every
possible um variation of barbell injury
from like dropping on your toe to like
clipping your chin when you're doing an
overhead press that is
awful have you ever done that yeah or
you might need your teeth yeah yeah
that's bad well i thought i thought of
you chris with it with these because
didn't you
wasn't the source of your back injury at
dumbbell clean
it was yeah correct so that's three
years three years i did that well
remember i don't know why i remember
that but
it's something that i always whenever
i'm like moving something into place i
always think like
be careful himself so yeah so like
whenever you're doing
a dumbbell overhead press if you're
doing like four sets
that's four maybe more so i'm actually
doing like
density style circuits with these with
dumbbells at the moment so it's multiple
sets of
low reps that's like 10 or 15 cleans
that i would have to do and i'm terrible
at them so
there's a recurring theme there like i
remember a few years ago i've got a
really crisp memory of me
lying on the floor like in tears and
chris
came with a care package of malt loaf
and smoothie and it was and like volta
roll it was really
really heartwarming and
that was because i think at like six in
the morning i had the 50 kilo dumbbells
trying to get them into place for a
seated bed lying bench press and like
it's when you try and get it onto your
thighs as the first step before you roll
back onto you
your back and i missed my leg and so i'm
like swinging around with one
dumbbell and i felt something peeing and
i was like oh i'll just deal with that
in a second
did my set while you're doing the set
you feel your back just going like
you're like oh no and then when i put
them down i was like i'm just gonna have
to go home
there's one other moment like that where
um someone we know
robbie was doing lateral raises with um
the metal dumbbells
and between reps he just dinked his bell
end
between the dumbbells and that was game
over he just like stops the workout
went home glanzo megalinegory isn't it
instant that would really hurt it really
really hurts
power hooks i like it seth what you got
this from aliexpress
i mean aliexpress should be the lifehack
actually because
it's a great way to just buy a bunch of
tut and i think i'm going to do a series
on youtube of ali i bought on aliexpress
yeah
so this is a lighter you know so chris
one of your recommendations a while ago
is have a long lighter so you can light
candles and stuff
this is basically how dodgy is this
can you hear that yeah so can you
describe for people that are listening
can you describe what it is
it looks dangerous it's a just basically
i think it's a taser
taser taser but it's a taser
but you just put it into the candle and
it lights up
you charge it with you usbc
wow that that i mean only on aliexpress
are you going to get that because
there's no way that it's legal i mean
what am i even going to call that like
buy a miniature taser to light a candle
illegal taser yeah like i'm so tempted
to just be like
but i feel like i might i was gonna say
have you done it put if you stuck
something in it
too scared if you don't just do it to
yourself just go
out really quickly i mean high voltage
is it
no but like so what do i start to gain
like i know it's gonna
it's gonna hurt in some way
i think you know you know where the
parameters are and also content yeah
so knowing how much it hurts is it i
think it's good
it's good to know like the lay of the
land isn't it or something like that
like okay
i did that once yeah i'll not do that
again yeah uh okay
uh what am i gonna do right so one of
the things that
i and probably almost everyone else have
been struggling with over the last year
has been
finding that sort of gas and that
motivation and that energy throughout
the day
not in a i need a coffee way
or i need to have some food more like
i've been on my own in my house working
or doing whatever and i just need to
feel
a little bit more energized the same way
that you would whenever you have a
conversation with someone or
have to get out of the car um and
especially before a podcast because i
tend to record on an evening
i'm trying to find you know at 6 00 p.m
i've maybe been up since
6 45 so it's 12 hours after i got up and
i've got to do the thing where i peak
perform
um so what i've taken to doing
is turning some music on like making a
miniature playlist of maybe sort of two
or three songs
on spotify and just doing a little
mobility circuit
of a couple of press-ups a couple of
squats um
you know maybe some stretches or for me
for my achilles some calf raises and
stuff like that
whilst listening to some music at a
fairly good volume
and the difference with a little bit of
blood flow
you'd think i'm gonna move more that
would make me more tired but
that time where you've got brain fog and
you know your thoughts aren't really too
clear
it's quite difficult to describe but you
know what i mean you just feel
foggy and not really sharp and on it
and um yeah like five minutes even just
five minutes of that and a
big glass of cold water i think a lot of
this
the unifying thread that we discovered
was when you told me about your
acupuncture mat
seth and you said it's just a state
change
you're just looking for something to
change the state that your body's in
could it be cold shower could it be
sauna could it be a walk could it be
some exercise with some music that gets
you emotionally invested into it
all of these different structures but
this is one that you can pretty much
always do no matter where you are you
can always go and do a little
couple of press-ups couple of squats
some music on and i feel
i feel better it's not a panacea for low
energy
but it it works more often than it
doesn't i really like that
just a little kick up the bum and it's
always accessible
yeah miniature little playlist on
spotify like some some good tunes from
when you were a little bit younger that
you absolutely love that are energetic
and then yeah you're away so my
i have a life hack it's very very
related to that a little bit different
but very related so
um specifically for like
so i think generally i underestimate i
think a lot of people underestimate
how a song can completely like night and
day change your mood
either for the for the better or the
worse and um something i've heard a lot
of people talk about but i've never
really done
is protecting your like training
playlists
so have songs in your you have a
playlist in spotify that you only listen
to
when you're training you have an idea
don't you have a pr song
i do yeah i have a few problems if that
comes on on shuffle and you're like
you've got to always have your belt on
underneath whatever clothes you're
wearing and you just
leave it on
picking up janice in the in the office
sorry janice how much do you wear
102 right brilliant
[Laughter]
yeah um but so the thing that i've
noticed especially is like
songs that you so i have a you know
every every year you get a
favorites thing on spotify like a 2020
favorites or whatever so i have a um
i have a playlist which is all of the
all of those
in one called just past favorites so
it's all of my my favorites from every
year
since like whenever i got spotify like
2015 so it's a lot
yeah because it's so advanced video
spotify you it feels
such it's what happens when you pay two
pounds a month for a membership
as opposed to use it as opposed to
sconing it for free yeah
okay so you've got all of these and then
what have you done have you made a top
filtering off the top of all of them
it's just that well so it's when when
some when something comes on generally
like allocation doesn't that players
have got nothing to
um nothing to listen to and there'll be
something coming like oh this is
like i haven't heard this song in three
years put in the training playlist
and only listen to it and it songs like
that just create this effect that
and we've all had it right like a song
that like comes on when you're somewhere
and you're like oh my god i've not heard
that in ages
so i have a training playlist that
you're always curating and always adding
things to
but protect it because those that effect
is
it diminishes the more you listen to
them
have a sacred training playlist yeah i
like that you can
you can do that with everything right so
you can have a sleep playlist a morning
playlist a work playlist
this is one of the things that um i've
been reading jonathan hates
the happiness hypothesis and he talks a
lot about the sacred and the profane
and there's not really much now that
people treat in normal day-to-day life
as sacred like if you actually think
about what it is it's
weird stuff like well it's it's obvious
stuff like not being molested on the
street like your personal body is sacred
right like obviously
but think about like other things around
rituals
like even people wear their shoes in
their bedroom people wear the shoes
they've been outside in in their bedroom
that would never be accepted in like a
subcontinental culture
like oh god if you did that in a muslim
household
yeah you'd get the slipper yeah you
would yeah but the slipper wouldn't
touch the floor the slipper would be off
and it would be there to beat you
you have to go outside to the porch take
the slipper
yeah exactly um yeah so i like i like
having more sacred things
like having routines i think that's part
of the reason why we all love having
morning routines right like it's sacred
sacred bit of time thank you very good
except for what you got
so um you guys might not be aware of
this but i i actually split
my life hacks into physical and digital
and so i'm attempting to
to alternate here um my digital one
is evernote legacy so i'm currently
a evernote refugee evernote for anyone
that doesn't know
they rolled out an update that was
basically a
global downgrade to every part of the
function of evernote it's lost its
fitness for purpose and so while i'm
waiting for another app to bridge the
gap and allow
import functionality which for me i've
got my eyes set on craft i'm just
waiting for the developers to allow
evernote import is you can use the
legacy version of evernote
um in the meantime so the hackers don't
upgrade to the new evernote
even though it looks nicer it just won't
work um stick with the legacy version
but the problem is
that's unsupported so as operating
systems
grow it's going to hit a point where
it's no longer compatible so by by
wanting to continue to use evernote
legacy you also can't update any other
parts of your operating system in case
it gets
it gets yeah exactly so this is this is
not a permanent
hack this is an interim measure until
can you downgrade let's say that i
accidentally upgrade to new evernote is
there a way that i can downgrade
you can but you might lose all your
notes because
yeah this is what haba is because
they've removed the offline
storage functionality so um
it's just risky business i wouldn't do
it
hopefully no big evernote fans are sat
there with the new version of evernote
i don't think anyone's a big fan of
evernote now man like notion
rome uh have just come in
and captured the attention on the
internet for all that this is exactly it
like evernote have stayed so far in the
past
and it's such a shame because there was
such a big company that had so much
capital and
you know put poison massive first mover
advantage
in the note-taking space as well right
like think about it
do you know what it is it's it's
blockbuster to netflix it's like
you had it all you had the brand equity
you had the user base you had the
the faith in the brand i don't trust
this new internet business
vhs tips and then you go all right fine
but if you can't get it on it [ __ ]
it's not worth a look unbelievable
okay i listened to johnny wilkinson on
the high performance podcast with jake
humphrey
uh and his scientific friend
and it's one of the best podcasts that
i've listened to in a very long time
if you want to hear someone that you
think
should just be a hard guy talking about
being in the present moment about
detachment from the ego
about embracing your true self all this
stuff and you just think like hang on i
thought
he was a like a posh meat head um and
johnny wilkinson just sounds like he's
done about 50 000 ayahuasca ceremonies
it's wonderful
and one of the things this is the the
rugby player john wilkins yeah yeah
yeah right man he's he's [ __ ] fully
awakened now
like absolutely fully awakened and the
episode's
amazing it's one of the best podcasts
i've ever heard um wow which is what
should we search for
it's johnny wilkinson high performance
podcast um
also on that show is eddie hearn
and eddie hearn you just think as the
same thing
kind of a essex wide boy idiot
with some cash behind him who
understands fighters nah
like he's quoting warren buffett he
talks about how he understands his inner
motivations from the way that his father
treated him as a kid
like the guy is switched on um he's just
so many more layers deep than i knew um
yeah both of those guys really changed
my opinion of them in great ways whilst
listening to them
but what i took from the johnny
wilkinson episode
is find joy today and what he talks
about
is that a lot of people presume that
happiness is something that they will
get
to enjoy in the future when they've got
past the things that they need to do
today
but the future never comes that joy has
to be found
in the moment and one of the most
consistent mantras
that i've written as part of moral
morning journaling moral journaling
has been has been just fine joy today
like find joy in the thing that you do
so this morning i went for a walk and
it's frost
like sharp frost on the floor but it's
really nice it's really still the sun's
sort of shooting through the clouds i
haven't got my phone on me
and i'm just able to be like this is
really really nice like this makes me
quite happy
the the sky's clear i can see birds
there was a dog on the other side of the
street i enjoyed the dog
like just finding joy today and not
presuming that it's a thing that you get
to do in the future once you've got
today out of the way
it's a really important point especially
for people that listen to this podcast i
think we're gonna
we're all gonna be more on the spectrum
of
deferring enjoyment and investing in
ourselves long term and
it's quite easy to lose sight of the
fact that you're still living your life
right now
and so finding some kind of inherent
enjoyment from things that you do day to
day is really important
i think you're quite good with that
journey obviously that was one of the
big reasons that you bought a dog
right was to kind of take you out of
that neurotic sort of self-involved
business involved mind and
i'm gonna kind of focus on another being
and
kind of just be present with it yeah
well it's it's
like there's just certain aspects of
having a dog that you just cannot avoid
like it needs
to be taken for a walk there's no it's
not negotiable really so
yeah and it is like the automating
laughing and happiness definitely daily
thing it's brilliant
johnny what you got it's me right so
my uh this hack is related to reading
speed but i should preface this with i
am now
big moment drum roll reading again
and the reason that i'm reading again
which is kind of a life hack within the
life hack
is something that yousef really kind of
flipped the switch my brain and
explained to me which is the
power of um things like evernote
craft all these bits of software i've
never really had a use for them i've
never really understood like
i just take notes and then don't refer
to the notes and it's just pointless
but hearing yousef explain this like
second brain idea
and how if you as you read a book or as
you listen to a podcast or
you're learning something that you think
like yeah i'll need this in future
then using that app as your
searchable database for information so
i've now when i'm writing notes about
books and when i'm writing notes about
like
q and a calls i'm listening to wrong
courses we're on i'm writing
as though like when i need this in the
future what will i what do i think i'll
search for
what do i think i'll type in to find it
so like this morning
you have asked me a question i was like
i'm sure i've typed
literally the key word in and suddenly
three or four notes that i've made on
that thing get brought up and i'm like
oh yeah i remember
that's already in my brain i just can't
recall it so i have to use something
else
so that means that i've kind of all
right it makes sense to read now i kind
of understand why i'm reading again
um and a tip related to that that i got
from mark manson
which you two may have already come
across when you're reading
you tend to have like the the inner
voice that's reading aloud
so you're like reading in your head and
that limits your reading speed
quite a lot and if you just stop that if
you just so like when you're watching a
film with subtitles
you don't read the words in your head as
the film's happening you just
look at it and you've read it and you
can do that with a book if you just
decide to do that with the books you
just look at the words
and you're like i've read the page and
lo and behold it's
it's there so just i suppose two in one
i've kind of jumped the queue a little
bit but
one of them is using something like
evernote if you have it as
whenever i learn something i'm going to
put it in here so that i can search for
this topic in the future and what would
that look like that note
and then secondly if you are then going
to read from that or read as a result of
that
just stop reading the words in your head
and you read way quicker nice so use
something like evernote but not evernote
but not enough [ __ ] well sorry youssef
recommended craft to me so that's what
i've started using
it seems at the moment like rome is is
really sort of picking up speed but i've
never touched rome i've seen notion
and a couple of other things what advice
have you got for
stopping the inner voice in your head
whilst reading other than just
saying stop
i don't know i think like what i
what i think of is if this exactly the
example i gave like if this were a film
and i was reading subtitles i would just
look at the words
like when you when you read things in
normal life when you're not trying to
read them
you still read the words like you've
still
you can still understand the sentence
written down like when you look at a
sign you don't go turn left at the next
exit
it's just you look at it and you
understand it
and you scan it quickly there's a tip
from tony buzan
about stopping this which is you give
your audiophonic loop
in your head something to do so you
either
think of a a tune that doesn't have
words
or you repeat something to yourself this
is an exercise this isn't something you
do
for all of your reading for the rest of
your life but it's just to be able to
learn that you can as johnny said you
can detach
the audiophonic loop from reading and
you don't have to be like
the cat sat on them
that's awesome that's a good tip yeah it
feels weird because
it feels like you're not reading
initially but if you kind of test
yourself on the recall of what have i
just read
it's amazing how like it took you
seconds to read the page when it
previously would have taken a minute
but you've still taken it all in the
problem i have with note taking whilst
reading
is that i don't sink into the content
anywhere near as deeply and this is why
for me reading on kindle and then using
progressive summarization highlighting
makes a lot more sense because you can
just go through
highlight as you go and then single
batch process the entire book
once you're done uh go back through and
make the the key takeaways
plus if you're using read wise which is
actually
i'll i'll just explain that one as my
next one after this
but if you're using read wise then
they'll deliver them to you on a daily
basis
so i suppose the the tip is more like
if you so i see like i was explaining
this to you stuff and you stuff's like
way further down the rabbit hole with me
than this stuff this is i'm just
learning
but i see omnifocus as like my ram
on a computer so like if something is
said to me
all i need to do is make sure it goes
from there
and into it and i know that i know that
that system will take care of it
and then the other thing so evernote or
craft or room or whatever
is like your hard drive so i don't need
it now i may never need it but if i have
a
findable version of it in the future
when i want to learn when i'm like i
want to
get more into meditation what are some
best what are the best results about
meditation
i'll just type meditation into my hard
drive
and oh yeah i read a book six months ago
about that
reference something tiny that now i can
make use of so that
doesn't really matter how you make the
notes i suppose as long as it's findable
whenever you want that thing in the
future that's a great analogy as long as
you have a
that as you start to build more and more
notes because i think i've got
five thousand also at this point that's
where you start to
need a decent tagging structure more and
more
and the benefit of tags as well as
notebooks there's no books are the
hierarchical structure that's
you know organized and you've you've
created it deliberately
but tags allow things to straddle across
multiple notebooks because they are
themes that are shared but don't
necessarily fit into a single
notebook and over time you start to
build this emergent structure
and eventually cross links between notes
that
previously didn't happen and that's why
the benefit of that's why rome has
become so popular because it allows
ideas to have sex with each other
or you can downgrade back from new
evernote to evernote legacy and just get
rid of all of your notes
and you don't have this problem at all
exactly
it's like the the men in black flash pen
isn't it but so
actually thiago forte um threw shade at
the new evernote
in a tweet recently saying like i love
how the new evernote
is like replicating the human brain by
like randomly forgetting certain notes
it's like a true second external brain
like it acts
like sometimes you can find it it's not
there anymore yeah brilliant you just
can't remember yeah what you got seth so
yeah
so this one is a physical life hack and
this is the
what does it say archipel or something
are support
yeah is this from aliexpress again this
is actually from amazon but i i you can
definitely get them from
aliexpress as well um and it is a
retractable
triple charger so it has all three
because everyone's got like
100 little usb cables that are different
end things and it's really and you've
got like a draw with them somewhere
this just has three in one it's a little
medusa
and it's got the big three so it has
that one
that one so is that us
usbc lightning and
micro usb yeah yeah and exactly it's on
a little sort of
retractable reel with ratchets on so you
can make it longer and shorter
it's fantastic because then it just
tidies up you
your room as well because we've got
those little devices you know like your
little taser
have you ever accidentally retracted it
whilst a device has been attached to it
and flung it across the desk
it either breaks the device or stops
charging it depending on how heavy the
device is
i have to say like everyone's gone
through a million charges across their
lifetime
and i treat my charges now with so much
care
i'm just like right i'm not gonna wind
them up like hard i'm just gonna keep
them as straight as possible
that device programs in the opposite
to that it's just stretching them and
bending them and twisting them around
yeah but it's it's in a controlled way
but yeah you're right like we all
just wonder how long it's gonna last
it's they've lasted like a year so far
but yeah we all know someone who's got
like
a charger that's like held together with
like bits of like hair bubbles and rope
and it's like
live wires like sticking out of it going
like that well haven't you isn't one of
your previous life hacks the
like the putty that you put at the end
of the sugar
sugru at the end of it just to stop it
from fraying because if you
if your mac charger phrase it's like
50 60 23 isn't it 80 quid
that was with student discount it was 86
quid with without
[ __ ] [ __ ] i've just i've just got
you by the curlies aren't they they
really do
they're short and clear uh right this is
the biggest
change i've made to my productivity in
2021
and probably been the single best thing
that i've done and johnny's gonna hate
me because
he's been doing it for ages it's called
first things first
so basically what is the one thing that
if i did it today
it would make the entire rest of my day
feel like a success
and you just do that when you sit down
at your desk um
i'm actually going to do i'm going to do
a doubler here
so first things first is just choose
what the highest leverage task the most
important task for the day is
that requires the most energy the most
input and do that
as you sit down one of the things that
i'm big into
is trying to remove the anxiety you have
of undone tasks
because of an open loop like it at the
end of every day you kind of shake the
etcher sketch
and you get to restart the next day but
each day you have to meditate
and exercise and go for a walk and do
the rest of it and the longer that you
get through your day without having done
that
the more that your mental ram is taken
up thinking about the fact that you
still need to do it
whereas if you can do those things first
in the morning i've already meditated
i've read i've done my journaling i've
got the main task for the day out of the
way the rest of the day just feels so
much more liberated
and you can genuinely enjoy it as
opposed to constantly having this like
future
task that you're concerned about so
first things first is important
and this is related to chris sparks's
number one productivity tip which is
plan what you're going to do today the
night before
um and he says that every one minute you
spend planning on the night before is
worth 10 minutes
the following day um so what i've been
using is
the six minute diaries new product which
is the six minute success journal
very similar to most other productivity
journals but i just prefer the process
that they've got
that'll be linked in on amazon and um
just my
evening routine now involves choosing
the task that thing they call it big
piece of cake
but it should it should be um what frog
do you want to eat
like what is the most high leverage
uncomfortable
but best return task that you need to do
and i'm just waking up on a morning and
i know what i need to do and if i do
that thing
even if the rest of the day is
completely awful it doesn't matter
so i've got this ted talk coming up and
like
planning for a ted talk to to go and do
some time writing at like three in the
afternoon
it's just bollocks but if you've got up
you've done your morning routine you sit
down at your desk and you nail two and a
half hours
planning a talk you're like right i've
done it that's it i've completed my day
now i don't care about these annoying
little emails because i'm like
it's like dancing through a dancing
through a daisy field because you just
feel like everything's already been
sorted
so yeah first things first and then plan
what you're going to do the night before
and the process i'm using for that is
the six minute success journal which i
think is absolutely awesome
fantastic it's a cool tip so i've got
i've got one so
on the same theme as that um
a lot of these things for me like tip
like productivity tips are things that
i learned like the first time i read
getting things done
whenever that was and i read at the time
i was like stupid
and then like six years later you're
like ah
now i understand so with the
the big piece of cake um style of of
things to do so like planning a ted talk
i think we all have on our to-do list
something like that or maybe
maybe your to-do list is full of things
like that that seems so large
and painful and difficult that you just
kind of never do anything with them
so actually what those are in gtd land
are projects not single actions and all
we can ever do is a single action so we
can never do is the thing that is the
one like
i'm going to do this and it's completed
so breaking something like that down
into single actions and then only
looking at the
one only considering the first step of
that project
is such an easy way to kind of always be
nudging things forward all the time in
your life so
like i wanna i don't know get some
artwork
from a room in my house like all right
oh god and then you sit down to try and
do it and there's
10 steps to it and you try and do all of
those at once you're probably not going
to do it
but if step one is ask a friend to
recommend
two websites that i can look at you can
fire that text off and
suddenly 10 projects are moving forward
every day in little ways
and there's not really any resistance to
it and before you know it they've all
been done
so basically the the hack is
if you've got anything on your to-do
list that you're considering doing today
that is a huge thing instead of that
break it down into ten things
into the ten steps so if you are
explaining to somebody else
how are you going to do this action what
are those ten steps look like
and the only the first one should be on
your to-do list if that makes sense
and that's that's for anyone who's read
getting things done that is just how
david allen explained it 30 years ago
whenever the book was read
it's only we've just come across it now
yeah
yeah it's um i think one of the main
reasons people procrastinate is that
they don't know
what to do next so a lot of the time
i'll speak to the boys that are in the
office
about an assignment that they're
struggling to do and they're like oh
mate
i was in the library all day yesterday
and i'm i'm here i was in the office
today and you know this i've got this
big assignment coming in
you know okay have you made the document
on which you're going to write the
assignment
oh well no i i mean right okay
and it's like so a big part of that
and i think me and yousef probably
suffer with this a little bit more than
you johnny
is to know that time dedicated to
planning
and reviewing is more important than
time dedicated to the task
like if you spend time before you do a
thing
constructing how you're going to do the
thing it makes
everything so much easier and if you
don't do it
that it's basically a different
challenge it's a totally different
challenge to try and
um manifest what do i need to do and
then how am i going to do it as opposed
to batching
okay first i'm gonna do this then i'm
gonna do that then i'm going to ring the
person then i'm going to get the
paperwork then i'm going to go baba
and just doing that and after that it's
literally just a case of
some some past version of you yeah step
after step
after step the next step from that is
sorry know just similar to the chris
sparks thing
that is it an ounce of planning is worth
a pound of execution or something like
that
um i definitely yeah i definitely do
struggle with if i haven't done that
i rode into the morning like a ps1 rpg
character
that walks into the wall and then
carries on walking and slowly rotates on
that axis
keeps walking yeah it's
a linked link it's just that
we presume if i can get started on this
task
now i'll make progress on this task now
planning's taking time away from me
doing the thing
you're like yeah but it's it's deciding
to drive to a place
without knowing where the place is or
the route you're going to take it's just
getting in the car
and putting your foot down like okay i
mean before that i should probably get
the map out have a look at the route
realize where i need to go and then i
can do it the the hidden benefit of all
of this
that you don't necessarily realize until
you've broken things down in that way
is that when you have like when you're
on a walk and you think oh i'll
call someone right or like i'll i've got
a bit of spare time i'll i'll call
someone
and you've got 20 projects in your life
broken down in the next steps
and five of them have things in them
with the tag
phone call you can make five phone calls
in the 15 minutes that previous you were
like at some point you need to make this
phone call
done done done and like fight all those
things to be moved forward so
it's kind of facilitating the when you
have you know
you sat waiting or you're on your phone
or you're browsing amazon
you think oh yeah i wonder if there's
anything that i've kind of forgotten
and you can see you can filter through
all of the little tiny subsections in
your life that
when i'm putting the art on the wall
that i'm going to buy i'm going to need
picture hooks i'm going to need
so done so it's just a way of like
reducing resistance i suppose planning
and then making things easier on
yourself in the future
and who doesn't want that everyone easy
things are nice aren't they
they're lovely so on the
the journal theme there's an app called
day one
which i can't remember if i've mentioned
it on a previous life hacks but
it is beautiful and it's very much
designed for journaling and diaries and
stuff so it bridges that gap where
johnny was talking about the ram which
is
working memory of your brain stuff that
needs doing and needs to be in the
system but isn't going to be stored long
term it's not going to be archived and
actually if it was in your
external brain it would clog things up
um
and then you've got the archive which is
the stuff that you want to refer to in
the future
but you might have this stuff in the
kind of in-between bay which is
reflective stuff that doesn't have an
immediate next action but
is a way to kind of take all these
thoughts and neuroses and patterns and
things and just put them into boxes and
clarify your own thoughts and um manage
your your emotions
and that's the whole purpose of a diary
or a journal and i think
i definitely see the value in in chris's
approach of like having a handwritten
journal that gives you prompts and
questions but if you're the kind of
person
that hates handwriting and you want a
free form
thing then day one is very good the
other benefit of it is that it's because
it's designed like a
diary it allows you to it tracks a lot
of data but it's all
held on your device um in terms of
location
photos that you took that day it's
designed to really create like a
tapestry of your life
so you can look back on it and it's it's
just quite a cool um
way to be like oh yeah this is like a
memoir
i use day one for more sort of
significant emotional life events
um it's also like password protected
which is kind of good so
people can't just stumble upon i mean to
be fair like my journal is not where the
worst stuff on my phone is
but my camera rolls got some fairly
awful stuff
as well so that that's a
that's another one when you like you
know you're trying to show someone oh
here's the um the new wall that i've had
painted and you have to like scroll
through the
and people are like look at my [ __ ]
camera roll mate
yeah so not to kind of bowl in
and do that like while i was doing it
before was cool i've been using day one
since february 2012. wow
so the the additional the additional
thing that it does
which you two may have had is like
occasionally it'll say
read this post on this day from five
years ago
it's been very well designed doesn't it
the thing the benefit i get from it is
like you know you you go down this like
personal development rabbit hole and you
think like is it really doing anything
i'm not really sure
and then you read something you read
like the the thoughts
that you were having four years ago my
favorite thing you look back on
something old you're like what
what i can't believe he was i think
there's an equivalent to hedonic
adaptation it's like productivity
adaptation
because you're always wanting to further
refine the edges and it's difficult to
remember how bad you were and also
you presume that as you get older you
should be compounding your effectiveness
so you don't want to be comparing your
your productivity now to your
productivity five years ago
but your mindset or a mindset around
yes around how you feel
and the thoughts that consume your
consciousness
that is really stark like when i think
man i once wrote in my day one
i once wrote a major concern
that the mc that spoke on the mic
over the r b dj in room two at riverside
had left and i was concerned that that
was going to ruin the room and that
would be the end of the business
and that was worthy of putting into into
my
like personal thought emotion journal
and now like i don't even know the name
of the person that does that
like it just doesn't it doesn't matter
it doesn't even arise in consciousness
there was something i read
a guy we've had on our podcast a couple
of times called john john romanello
talks about
the value of having like a long-standing
journal being
you just you realize like firstly
brilliant things and terrible things
come and go they pass and you have got
through all of the things that have been
the worst things that have ever happened
to you
and now it's fine so like you can read
back to how you were dealing with what
you perceived to be
the worst thing ever at the time and
like journaling at the time helps
a bit because you get to write it down i
guess and like externalize the
the mental talk but being able to look
back on that three years later and go
you know what if anything like that
happens again it'll probably be okay
it's just a nice like tapestry of this
is how
my thoughts evolved now when something
similar happens i deal with it better
so yeah i think it's it and day one i
think it's probably the best
app for it isn't it there's nothing as
well i think it's a paid version for
extra features too but yeah it's got a
partner app on
macbook as well doesn't it those are
links in
a little tab at the top like a little
bookmark thing that drops down yeah
i've only recently got the phone up to
be honest
that's like the all that it's like music
you listen to
or is it does it do that on the mac app
as well
not as much the the phone app as you
said yeah it's more designed for the
tapestry
i think it gives you prompts as well
it's not totally free form like i think
you can
it can say like what's the so it's the
it's the phone app where i get like the
see what you were doing in
january have you got notifications for
day one turned on
wow to be
allowed through the gate that is your
notification barrier
special i've got it got a life hack
related to that as well interesting
deliveroo i think is the only
deliveroo and phone calls are the only
two your food is coming
yeah that's it that's all i'm bothered
about so the only things that day one
notifies me about is either read this
journal entry which is always
interesting
and like you can set the notification to
fill the journal in to be randomized
and i think that's the best way what you
do what have you done this week or
whatever
yeah and so like that i just use that as
the prompt and if there's nothing
interesting i just don't bother
so that's really cool yeah i've got to
be fair all of these um
all these different functions i haven't
bothered
digging into right um so this is one
that i realized last year and it's a bit
of an uncomfortable truth
but i think i'm really enjoying telling
people things that they don't want to
hear
at the moment so i got shouted out on
the internet for talking about
trump and then i got shouted out on the
internet for talking about existential
risk and i got shouted out on the
internet
for talking about the single biggest
predictor of extramarital sex being
pre-marital sex
um but facts don't care about your
feelings and this is another one of them
the thing that you need to remember
whoever you are that's listening is that
you are the
common denominator in every experience
within your life
so imagine that
you always seem to be looked over for
promotions at work
or people just your partners always seem
to kind of get sick of you after around
about six months
or your friends always do invite you out
to things or you always are the first
person that gets picked for the sports
team or whatever it is
both good and bad if there is a
recurring theme in your life you are the
common denominator not
them so a lot of the time i'll have a
conversation with someone i had a
conversation with someone yesterday
who i regularly sort of spend
semi-regularly speak to maybe
once every couple of months and the
conversation always has the same
tone to it always has the same sort of
feeling it's a little bit antagonistic
so it's quite sort of debatey it's a
little bit self-righteous
and um i remember saying like man like
is is this how you are with everyone is
that no
no i was like well i don't have this
conversation with
anyone else but you so
it like in the nicest way possible it's
not me
like i only do this when you arrive so
you're the common denominator within
this situation and
it just reminds us that so much of what
happens in life
is within our control at least with
regards to our responses and the way the
tenor
that we have when we do things so yeah
remember that you're the common
denominator
so if ever there's a theme if it ever's
like something happens more than it
doesn't
you think well if it's normally
happening to me
then i probably have some involvement in
it yeah
i mean imagine if imagine if you always
if whenever there's a problem you always
deal with it
like you're the common denominator like
you are you are dealing with the
problems and
the reason it's uncomfortable truth is
that it forces us to realize
that our failures are ours to bear but
also our successes are ours to bear
especially if they're consistent it's
not a
truth that a lot of people would accept
or want to hear because
they get more benefit from being the
victim or the martyr or the
whatever the the role that they're
playing than they do from taking
personal responsibility and
taking agency um and i think
yeah i can see how if you say that to
certain people
like oh you know that thing always
happens to you it doesn't happen to
anyone else so
maybe it's it can be
like oh well no because they're just all
a day like every boss i've ever had has
been a dick or everybody every
ex-girlfriend
has always found me to be possessive
okay
like what's more likely that all of them
happen to have the same weird quirk or
that you are the person that is causing
it
i mean the problem is obviously there
are things that aren't our fault and
there are things that go wrong which are
out of our control
and that are unfortunate and unlucky so
the kernel of truth that this could have
occurred once you could have been with a
girl who was an absolute or a guy who
was an absolute
dick to you and said that you were a
bunch of ways that you're not
that can be true but if that continues
to happen
then with a higher and higher confidence
interval the probability
of it being them becomes lower
yeah there's also just no downside to
doing like the
the jocko willing like just taking
complete responsibility for everything
because
there's never really like yeah it's it's
it might make you feel a bit sad
but like at least you're trying to solve
the problem
and working towards a a solution or an
improvement
that's a good point like even when it's
not you it still probably benefits you
to
just be like well i'll just take a try
anyway
johnny are we still on long form or
we're doing quickfire
uh yeah let's do a quick let's do a
quick fire also if you've
watched anything on netflix or read
anything recently probably a good place
to throw some
some stuff in here okay so i have some i
have some fitness-y ones
some quick ones um quite a lot of people
i know myself included
are very consistent with like a
multivitamin and vitamin d
but quite inconsistent with creatine i
don't know whether either of you
have this problem you have just
described me my friend
so i have had this problem in my life
for
ages for like as long as i can remember
and it's actually credit to my protein
who fixed this so they sent us a
box of stuff uh to review like
pre-christmas
and in that box was a
tub of creatine tablets creating
monohydrate tablets
that like i'd always looked over because
i thought well you know what benefits
that
but now i just take five creatine
tablets when i take my multivitamin
and i always take my creatine that's
great
that's a good way to put it in because
the only time that you have creatine
if you're not having it in tablet form
is if you also have a shake
and you don't always have a shake every
day exactly
so i like i very rarely miss vitamin d
because it's like in the morning with
breakfast
like multivitamin vitamin d and then
creatine
later i'll mix some kind of like squash
and water and i'll have it then and i
always forget
i like this again there's more steps
involved in creatine i think off the
back of that
i have been more consistent with
creatine recently but
that's because one i use korea pure
rather than creatine monohydrate which
is
the same but it's just more purified it
doesn't give me the same nausea that
normal creation does um which is again
it just
like the whole james clear thing like if
it's unpleasant to do if it makes you
feel nauseous then you're like
yeah you're like well i'll have it after
my meal not before and um
and also mixing in with hot water so if
i have a morning cup of tea
i'll have it before or after the tea i
just can't i just cut the out the
thought of putting like creatine in my
morning coffee
just feels what is it just coffee
with a little bit of hot water not
boiling so all those too
yeah the the only downside of the
tablets are they are quite big
so if you like if you're not great with
taking tablets in general
um but i've actually found it's a nice
quite nice thing to to train yourself so
i
initially had to do one tablet at a time
now i'm just all five in at once
when johnny was at mine and i ordered a
big bag of carrots and he helps me put
them away in the fridge
so that i could train that as well um
anyway my next life hack
is blob opera
so this is a digital one and
it's i mean it's very very high brow um
google have
made a series of ai projects
and blob opera is an ai
um opera thing
there's five blobs and they've all got
faces and each one is like tenor and
soprano and
bass and whatever and depending on how
you move the mouse or your finger or if
you're doing it on your phone
they do different harmonies and
different and you can actually produce
some really beautiful blob operas so
if you're listening search for blob
opera on google
have a play around and say goodbye to
your evening because you'll be
so it's making music you specific you
produce the music
yeah and you can record them send them
to friends can you see
popular ones that other people have done
i think you can
i don't know how there must be a library
of them somewhere i've seen the videos
it's they're quite sort of cute
characters and they all go like
yeah exactly like that don't they yeah
stand up straight and open their mouth
uh right so i have been i've sent this
to a bunch of different people and i
also put it in my newsletter but it's
going to go in here
red rising uh is a series by pierce
brown
who is going to come on the podcast once
he finishes writing his sixth book
but it's just every single person that
i've given this fiction series to has
become addicted and
it's consumed quite a lot of their life
so please
take care with this life hack i am
warning you now
um but red rising's it's a really easy
to read
very fast-paced engaging it's i guess it
would technically probably fall under
sci-fi but there's a lot of sort of
history references in there
and it's just to do with politics and
backstabbing and there's this guy rising
up through the ranks and he's
infiltrating different societies but the
whole world very similar to the harry
potter thing the whole world feels quite
encompassing
uh red rising guns gonna read it and the
first one
is is sick and then there's five in the
series
that you can get suck into if you enjoy
it so highly recommended
nice um is it me
go away when so you probably heard one
of the tips is turn
all notifications off do you mention
before like i think you should have most
if not all notifications off
the problem i found with that i don't
know whether you two i think you have
changed to what i'm about to say and
what you do with this chris but when i
did that i was like right
it's full blackout like i don't want
anything i don't want the badge
notifications i want the noises i don't
want anything
and what that actually started to create
was a a worse version
of the like app spiral of you'll go on
your phone you're like look at your
email
like all right there's a new email so i
think i wonder if there's any whatsapp
so i'll have a look at what's up
and then before you know you're back at
email again and basically turning
notifications off
all that does is creates well i need to
go and check when something new
because there's no way but no other way
of knowing so basically
turning all notifications off but
leaving the red badge
on allows you to relax a bit
because you can see that i know it's
like you can see it accumulating but
there's no need to go in and check
and with things like imessage sometimes
if you open imessage and it opens on
someone's message
that's then and that's then marked as
unread and you think you can easily
forget about it so
for me leaving the notification badge on
but it doesn't
bombard me when i want to look at my
phone i'm like okay i've got some emails
i've got some what i've
got some eye messages i can't respond
now but i'll look at them later for
example
so i'm terrible with replying to things
pretty much everyone who knows me knows
that i'm terrible at replying things
and i think this has contributed to that
over time i think
not not having the badge on not having
any way of knowing there's unprocessed
stuff in that app
means like it's easy to forget so that's
really helped me recently
yeah i had notifications turned off
fully for whatsapp for a while and
i've sent sent and received millions of
whatsapp messages
over the last few years um
from my like for me i still keep badges
off i've been through the
value of despair that you went through
and
now because i like to use the web app
for whatsapp i like to use imessage on
my desktop and
i don't ever have emails that are urgent
not anymore
you guys may but nothing that i ever
receive if it's urgent they'll ring me
and if it's not i'll check in when i
check in and i'll check in on my laptop
so i think this is it's a really good
point and it's one that i still i do
agree with
but i think i've found a technique that
works slightly better for me for where
i'm at at the moment
i think you're even further through the
evolution by the sounds of things
i mean chris's global what's up
analytics for
total number of messages sent and
received makes me want to throw up
it's actually you get invited to like
the what's up annual conference of like
heaviest users yeah it's in like the the
teraflops of
oh here's the thing that i learned the
um
entire internet in terms of the
electrons that make up the data
not the storage devices that they're on
but the electrons that make up the data
is smaller than an orange
is that if you push them all together
and there's no space between yeah
i don't know what to make of that piece
of information chris
also if you were to write out on
double-sided a4 paper
all of the information that is generated
by the internet every day
and then stack them up in a single stack
they'd go from here to the sun and back
four times
daily daily yeah
i suppose it depends on how big your
handwriting is doesn't it but it either
way you get into the sun
yeah so yeah yeah it's an effort so what
you got
i may have mentioned this before but
upgrade to the maximum internet that
your
location allows just
like for the sake of an extra 20 quid or
something to have
the fastest internet like just think of
the amount of time that that saves
overall like all these little all these
little bits of time waiting for
something to buffer or waiting for a
page to load
and if that's just eliminated like you
so this was actually from george mcgill
when he was just saying you should
always pay for more speed
because if you can eliminate friction
for stuff then
amazing and now we're going to hit a
point soon
where this is no longer applicable for
most humans because then we'd be limited
by
the person i think me and johnny have
talked about this um
in terms of using alfred or using
software that makes you really fast at
something when actually
now it's your brain that's the slow
thing which is great like
we want things to move in that direction
but that's why like
the m1 macbook pro it's fast
it's good and if you're like a power
user of mac
then you will get the full use out of it
but for a lot of people like if you ever
use the trackpad to like
go to the address bar and then type
google.com and then scroll with it
like just don't bother with any of this
stuff like get a chromebook until you
can
max that out so i think the the whole um
moral of that story is like whatever
technology you use squeeze the lemon of
it and then say right i've earned the
right to upgrade
to the next level of speed um just
making sure that you're never
bottlenecked
by the technology so the bottlenecking
is the big thing because it's like
the so i have this conversation with
people who think that macs
are worse than pcs and they'll say like
oh well i've built my own pc
and it's got i've got my ram i've got
more ram than you have and i spent half
the money
it's like that's that's a valid argument
until you have to restart your computer
once because the app looks great like
yeah
the microsoft office crashed or it
doesn't work
and it's the same with internet like
yeah you save 20 quid a month and that
might be
you know great across a year but if you
have to deal with like a day
on that every day a video that buffers
for a minute
think how long that accumulates it's
like the whenever you
bottleneck by something regularly it is
usually worth just paying to remove the
problem
and then you just never realize it's
just a it's an emotional
thing like i tweeted the other day
saying like does anyone have a
legitimate reason
for um having a pc over a mac
and all the answers were like oh well if
i want to
change the the graphics card on this
thing i will
okay but like they're all special
special use cases
yeah if anyone does have a legitimate
reason
for using a windows operating system
computer
over a macbook please leave it in the
comments below
i'm i'm more than happy to to have my
mind changed
about this but every use case is
specific
like if just windows computers just
don't work the same way
as max to use both like day-to-day i
probably use a windows computer
more in total hours than the nhs than
mac and there's just
no comparison i mean in fairness i'm
using like windows 98 or something so
yeah the reasons are always like oh i
use this bit of like stock trading
software and it only works
okay specific case like mtv we're
talking about
general general day-to-day use
of just using a computer well the
solution is
you you give two people eight hours in a
different device and you say right
you've got this
late you've got this section of work to
do off you go
see who [ __ ] you know yeah it's not
evening so this
actually relates to the people who are
on uh macbook
yousef told me about this when i first
got my mac i think or when you first
maybe
alfredded me by pressing control command
and space
you bring up an emoji keyboard and you
can select them from there
now seth has gone one step further and
put an
alfred emoji shortcut in
which means that he can do it directly
from his alfred dashboard but presuming
that you don't want to go that
that deep and i even though i'm an avid
alfred user
i still use control command space a lot
of the time i think because
i don't actually know quite the emoji
that i need i'm like oh this is an emoji
that it's it's like a bolt but it's is
it electric or is it not even that i'm
just i want inspo
i want emoji so i'll have a little look
i'm like oh
should it be an apple should it be an oh
is that croissant
like you know i mean i just want to have
a is that is that a potato
there is a potato i think there's a
sweet potato now as well yeah exactly
this is technically a sweet potato
by the way as well so sorry about that
yeah fair enough i think if you want to
browse the emojis
there's another app actually that does
that but slightly
slightly quicker called rocket for mac
there's like three dollars which is
worth it
it's very similar to the command space
um
control just slightly more nicer
interface
interesting should we leave it there
gents i think uh we got some in the tank
still for for moving forward that was
really good
i've er yeah it was awesome
i've written everything in the show
notes below if you want to go and check
them out i will find some
links for a waterproof paper and pencil
and a miniature taser
where i can uh if there are any discount
codes that i've managed to find as well
i'll throw them in two
if you enjoyed it if you've got your own
life hacks just put them in the comments
or dm me at chris will
x wherever you follow me where should
people go if they want to check out more
of your stuff boys
two places if you're thinking like oh
online coaching those guys do online
coaching
their life looks so appealing
propanefitness.com forward slash
modern wisdom if you just want some
macros for free
then propanefitness.com use the
calculator on the main page
and a new url if you're just thinking
about starting an online business or you
want to learn a little bit more
about how to go online propane
fitness.com
mw business and you got it right i did
got it right
yes indeed i love it gentlemen thank you
for this we will come back we will do
more lifehacks soon
it is a pleasure thanks man speak to you
you